[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france et au
sommaire aujourd'hui la pandémie de kobe
19 et son impact sur les zones de
conflit occasion pour faire la guerre ou
bien la paix cette crise sanitaire
mondiale a affecté les principaux
conflits de la planète et parfois les
choses virent au désastre humanitaire
alors comment la propagation du nouveau
coronavirus at elle influencé la
sécurité dans le monde
tout d'abord l'activité terroriste ne
cesse de s'exacerber en syrie en irak ou
dans la bande du sahel
les djihadistes profite du confinement
pour lancer de nouvelles attaques
meurtrières au yémen tout comme en libye
les parties du conflit se servent du
confinement pour renforcer leurs
positions
de son côté l'onu appelle à plus de
retenue et demande un cessez le feu
global
une initiative qui reste pourtant sur le
papier malgré le soutien du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu tout comme la
proposition du secrétaire général de
lever toutes les sanctions unilatérales
qui empêche les états sanctionné de
lutter contre la pandémie cette idée
n'est surtout pas du goût de washington
et bruxelles afin d'aider les pays les
plus vulnérables l'onu lançant plan de
réponse humanitaire mondial or pour le
mettre en oeuvre l'organisation aura
besoin de plus de 10 milliards de
dollars
la situation se complexifie avec le
départ des etats-unis de le ms qui était
de loin le plus gros contributeur à
l'agencé onusienne
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici en
quelques chiffres l'impact du comique 19
sur le monde et la sécurité globale
c'est le blick à ce jour 100 88 pays ont
été touchés par le virus plus de 26
millions de personnes ont été
contaminées et plus de huit cent
soixante quinze mille ans sont décédées
les etats-unis sont le pays le plus
touché avec plus de 6 millions de cas et
plus de 180 6000 décès vient ensuite
l'inde le brésil la russie le pérou et
la colombie en moins danan la pandémie
de kobe 19 a entraîné une crise
humanitaire d'une ampleur sans précédent
entre 83 et 132 millions de personnes
risquent d'être affectées par la famine
le taux de pauvreté repart à la hausse
pour la première fois depuis 1998 ainsi
33 millions de personnes de plus vont
être contraintes de vivre avec moins de
deux dollars par jour
la pauvreté extrême risque de pousser
9,7 millions d'enfants hors de l'école
un coup dur étaient également portés à
la sécurité mondiale
profitant de la pandémie de nombreux
groupes terroristes redoublent leurs
attaques dans des zones de conflits
nombreux sont les cas où le processus de
paix se trouve gelé en raison du
confinement exemple le différend
territorial entre le soudan et le soudan
du sud enfin la pandémie risque de
bouleverser le cours des conflits dans
des points chauds de la planète comme le
yémen ou la libye
le coc vie 19 plonge l'humanité dans une
crise sans précédent économie santé
enseignement tous les domaines de la vie
sont profondément atteint et c'est
surtout un défi majeur dans les pays en
proie à des conflits ou la situation
sécuritaire était déjà bien dégradée par
exemple la syrie et l'irak où l'état
islamique redouble d'activité mails
encore plus d'attac profitant du fait
que les militaires sont souvent occupés
à faire respecter le confinement
l'escaladent détention est constatée
aussi au yémen où les rebelles houthi
ont utilisé le cessez le feu unilatéral
de la coalition saoudienne pour
s'emparer de vastes territoires dans le
nord du pays en libye
la propagation du virus a poussé le
gouvernement d'union nationale a déclaré
un cessez le feu
sauf que celui-ci est fragile car
l'armée du maréchal haftar n'entendent
pas du tout le respecter et cela malgré
des appels répétitif de l'onu au cessez
le feu mondiale
le conseil de sécurité a d'ailleurs
adopté une résolution appelant à l'
arrêt des combats mais celle ci est
restent lettre morte tout comme une
autre initiative du secrétaire général
qui consiste à lever toutes les
sanctions unilatérales empêchant
certains états de lutter contre la
pandémie idée qui est rejetée en bloc
par bruxelles et washington
comment explique-t-il ce refus par quels
moyens le nu compte l aider les pays en
guerre quels défis empêche la mise en
oeuvre de toutes ces mesures onusiennes
enfin comment la pandémie at-elle
affecté les conflits en cours dans les
points les plus chauds du monde
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons tout de suite meriam belrad
docteur en sciences politiques de
l'institut d'études politiques de paris
madame meinrad beaux jours bonjour tout
d'abord première question quelles zones
de conflit selon vous est la plus
affectée par le cos vite 19 aujourd'hui
alors je dirais qu'il n'ya pas une zone
en particulier mais enfin je vois trois
continents particulièrement touchés du
fait de leur vulnérabilité de leur
fragilité sociaux politiques et
institutionnelles tout d'abord
l'amérique latine on a bien vu que les
pays latino américains énormément de mal
à s'adapter mais c'est parce que les
situations et les pays d'amérique latine
sont extrêmement fragiles sur le plan
politique et institutionnel
donc les états n'ont pas été en mesure
de répondre à l'urgence sanitaire comme
d'autres ont pu faire ailleurs
ensuite évidemment le moyen orient qui
est ravagé par la guerre par les
conflits depuis des années où on a un
enchevêtrement en fait des fragilités
des vulnérabilités et le colis 19 est
venu rajouter du désastre au désastre
donc on sait très clair par exemple dans
des pays comme l'irak la sueur et la
ligue
oui même dans d'autres pays moins
frappés par la guerre et enfin je dirais
que la situation très inquiétante pour
la suite c'est évidemment l'afrique qui
a été en tout cas un certain point
relativement épargnée mais ça ne veut
pas dire que à terme l'afrique ne
pourrait pas devenir une bombe à
retardement concernant les taux de
contamination la gestion qui sera fait
pour l'instant les pays africains ont
essayé d'y répondre quand il le pouvait
avec des moyens limités aussi vous
pensez que la propagation de l'épidémie
de kobe 19 pourraient affecter de
nouvelles zones de conflits dans le
monde dans un futur proche
oui alors je ne vois pas de
déstabilisation par exemple majeur en
europe l'europe est par ailleurs déjà
déstabilisé par un certain nombre de
problématiques irrésolus mais ce que
cette crise va générer c'est évidemment
énormément de colère sociale du fait
d'une précarisation des populations
d'une récession qui va être terrible
et de ce point de vue il faudra apporter
des réponses or le problème c'est qu'il
n'a pas de par exemple sur le cas de
l'union européenne on voit très bien que
les pays de l'union européenne agisse de
manière assez isolés ils ont été
incapables de s'entendre sur un plan de
relance dont tout cela vient fragiliser
les réponses la gestion est évidemment
va amplifier la colère de la société
civile qui a été frappé de plein fouet
par la crise qui va en connaître les
effets socio-économiques progression du
chômage de masse et précarité à grande
échelle
on n'a pas aujourd'hui vraiment de
vision claire mais en tout cas la colère
elle est là et elle va perdurer ça c'est
évident merci beaucoup madame belgrade
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous reviendrons vers
vous bien sûr à la fin de l'émission
pour plus de détails sur cette question
merci récession mondiale crise sanitaire
humanitaires locaux vides 19 change
petit à petit la face du monde
pourtant c'est surtout son impact sur la
sécurité globale qui inquiète de plus en
plus à lui la pandémie ducobu 19
continue d'affecter profondément la paix
la sécurité à travers le monde
la situation sécuritaire se détériore
surtout dans les pays en proie à des
conflits ou
les groupes radicaux profite souvent du
confinement pour renforcer leurs
positions l'exemple le plus criant est
l'activité grandissante de l'état
islamique au moyen-orient en syrie les
jadistes annonce en mars une nouvelle
opération militaire contre l'armée et
les milices alliées 133 soldats syriens
sont tués durant les deux premiers mois
une autre offensive et lançait ensuite
contre les positions des forces pro
gouvernementales syriennes dans la
région de jaca cette opération subie
pourtant un échec écrasant en irak les
terroristes en font aussi surface en
raison des mesures de prévention contre
le virus le nombre de militaires en
service et a chuté de 50% et les
jihadistes n'ont pas tardé à en profiter
rien qu'en mai 2020 il mène 138 attaque
ne soit presque quatre fois de plus
qu'en janvier
l'une des pires d'entre elles est
perpétrée début mai à samara les
combattants de l'état islamique tué au
moins 10 membres de la milice irakienne
lors d'un assaut coordonné durant la
nuit le nul ne veut surtout pas
minimiser la menace selon ses
informations près de 10000 jadis serait
actif en syrie et en irak
or il ne faut pas oublier les filières
régionales de l'état islamique qui
profitent aussi de l'occupation des
militaires pendant la période du
confinement dans la région du sahel par
exemple l'état islamique conclu en
février une trêve avec al-qaïda son
adversaire au moyen-orient son objectif
est d'unir leurs forces pour essayer de
prendre le contrôle d'une grande partie
du territoire de l'afrique de l'ouest
juste en dessous du désert du sahara
dans les pays comme le mali le niger et
le burkina faso et la conclusion de cet
accord les deux groupes commencent
intensifié leurs activités attentats à
l'explosif tirer embuscade contre la
police et l'armée
le bilan est lourd ces attaques font des
centaines de mains leur violence n'a pas
manqué d'attirer l'attention de l'onu
qui met en garde contre de lourdes
conséquences pour la sécurité régionale
nous assistons à des tentatives de la
part de terroristes et d'autres groupes
de la région de tirer parti de la
pandémie pour saper l'autorité de l'état
et déstabiliser les gouvernements
il faudra des années pour reconstruire
les communautés affectées au sahel
en plus d'affecter la stabilité
régionale la pandémie risque d'avoir un
fort impact sur les conflits dans les
points les plus chauds du monde le yémen
en est la meilleure illustration
le 8 avril la coalition dirigée par
l'arabie saoudite annonce un cessez le
feu unilatéral fixé pour deux semaines
mais prolonger ensuite pour un mois il a
été présenté comme une réponse à l'appel
de l'onu
or les rebelles houthi refuse de se
joindre à l'accord profitant d'une
relative accalmie
ils prennent le contrôle de vastes
territoires au nord du pays et capture
plusieurs bases militaires saoudiennes
parallèlement il lance des attaques de
drones et de missiles contre plusieurs
villes en arabie saoudite
en réponse le royaume wahhabite ronde
d'abord le cessez le feu et lance
ensuite une entente offensive contre les
positions des outils cependant si au
yémen la pandémie a eu comme résultat
l'intensification des combats
un autre conflit perd au contraire en
intensité à cause ou plutôt grâce à
l'aggravation de la crise sanitaire
il s'agit de la guerre civile en libye
le 21 août le gouvernement d'union
nationale de sa rage proclame un cessez
le feu unilatéral en raison de la
propagation rapide de kovy de 19 cette
initiative est soutenue par le parlement
libyen basé à tobrouk qui soutient
l'autre force du conflit il s'agit de
l'armée nationale libyenne dirigée par
khalifa haftar seul problème le maréchal
afta lui-même refusent de déposer les
armes
selon lui l'initiative de sa rage ne
serait qu'une manoeuvre pour préparer
une nouvelle offensive sur la ville de
syrte port d'entrée des installations
pétrolières
profitant de l'arrêt momentané des
combats les forces daft à renforce la
défense de la ville étendant même temps
de repousser les positions de l'ennemi
alors qu'en libye la crise sanitaire
ouvre une fenêtre d'opportunité
pour amorcer un dialogue politique elle
a un effet inverse dans un autre conflit
africain celui qui se joue entre le
soudan et le soudan du sud
ces deux pays se disputent la région
d'abyei 640 policiers internationaux
c'est la force onusienne qui devrait
être déployé sur place actuellement
cette décision est prise en 2019 par le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu or
l'arrivée du personnel onusien à abyei
s'avère impossible en raison de la
pandémie en mars 2020 le soudan qui
contrôle le territoire disputé ferme les
frontières au nez de la mission
onusienne
sans surprise la situation sème
l'inquiétude au sein des nations unies
qui dénonce des retards importants dans
la mise en place de la résolution et
parle d'une aggravation de la situation
sécuritaire dans la région
alors comment le nu tente-t-elle d'aider
les pays en conflit
quels sont les défis qui se posent sur
son chemin enfin quels sont les progrès
déjà réalisés par les agences onusiennes
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
la pandémie de kobe 19 n'épargne aucune
région du globe l'onu parle du plus
grand défi depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale et aujourd'hui dix mois après
l'enregistrement du premier cas
l'origine du virus et son apparition de
pose toujours autant de questions retour
sur les faits c'est à la fin du mois de
décembre 2019 que le premier cas de
coronavirus serait apparue en chine
en effet des chercheurs chinois ont
identifié un nouveau virus qui affecte
au départ une dizaine de personnes
employés et clients d'un marché dans la
province de hunan dans le centre de la
chine
ce virus devient très vite l'épicentre
de la pandémie
début janvier 2020 un premier mort de ce
virus est identifié en chine il aurait
lui aussi fréquenté ce marché de one
malgré le confinement de la région en
seulement quelques semaines plusieurs
régions de chine et d'autres pays
asiatiques sont touchés même si le virus
se concentre d'abord en asile oms
insiste en janvier 2020 sur le fait que
l'épidémie de coronavirus constitue une
urgence de santé publique de portée
internationale
pourtant de nombreux pays tels que le
brésil les états unis le royaume uni le
mexique tente au début 2010 et
l'expansion et les dangers du coc vie 19
pourtant sa propagation s'accélère de
manière exponentielle gagnant dès la fin
du mois de janvier 2020 la plupart des
continents
alors que le virus s'installe hors des
frontières de chine de nombreux pays
soupçonnent ces dernières d'avoir
étouffé l'émergence du virus et de ne
pas avoir adopté des mesures adéquates
les etats unis avancent même avoir des
preuves que le laboratoire de one aurait
créé ce virus washington envisage
d'imposer des sanctions à pékin l'ue
veut de son côté va même jusqu'à accuser
la chine et la russie d'être les forces
directrices de la désinformation sur la
pandémie
le tout sans preuve sur fond de bataille
diplomatique le virus continue pourtant
de se propager
faute de vaccins disponibles alors que
de nombreux laboratoires aux quatre
coins du monde se lance dans une course
au vaccin
la russie affirme en août dernier avoir
enregistré un premier vaccin assez
efficace une partie de la communauté
internationale accueille pourtant cette
nouvelle avec scepticisme en soulignant
le manque d c'est plus poussé du vaccin
sur l'homme
pour l'instant le virus a causé plus de
huit cent soixante quinze mille morts
selon l'institut john hopkins
selon le fmi le pib mondial pourrait
chuter de 3%
du jamais vu depuis la grande dépression
des années 1930
pourtant dans des zones de guerre le
virus a des conséquences encore plus
désastreuses que dans les autres parties
du monde
déjà fragilisée avant la pandémie elles
le sont encore plus à présent en effet
les programmes d aide humanitaire sur le
terrain sont pour la plupart réduit la
cause principale c'est le manque de
financements supplémentaires de la part
des états donateurs qui doivent eux
mêmes faire face à cette crise
multidimensionnelle sans précédent
c'est notamment le cas au yémen selon
l'unicef en raison du manque des deux le
nombre d'enfants mal nourris pourrait y
atteindre 2,4 millions d'ici la fin de
l'année soit une hausse de 20% par
rapport à l'année précédente
de plus les rares structures de santé
dans les zones de conflits manque de
moyens ainsi que de personnel pour
assurer le dépistage et la prise en
charge des malades en libye par exemple
ni pointe du doigt le fait qu'il n'y a
tout simplement pas d'organisation
spécifique ou d'instituts responsable
des urgences de santé publique
difficile de savoir précisément qui a
contracté le coronavirus et donc
d'empêcher sa propagation
ennemi imprévisible le défi pandémique
s'adresse à l'humanité toute entière
une occasion pour le nu de mettre en
pause toutes les guerres de la planète
sans condition et sans délai la furie
avec laquelle sa balle virus montre bien
que ce faire la guerre est une folie
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'appelle
aujourd'hui à un cessez le feu immédiat
partout dans le monde l'heure est venue
de laisser les conflits armés
derrière nous pour concentrer nos
efforts sur le véritable combat de nos
vies en deux semaines 70 pays
souscrivent à l'appel onusien avait
rejoint ils sont 170
sans oublier l'union africaine et
l'union européenne le pape françois et
l'archevêque de cantorbéry plusieurs ong
et des millions de pétitionnaires dans
cette marée de soutien une seule voix
bris longtemps par son absence celle du
conseil de sécurité l'organe le plus
puissant de l'onu mais plus de trois
mois à rejoindre l'appel à la trêve et
concrétiser sa durée 90 jours pourquoi
ne l'at il pas fait plus tôt
et bien parce qu'il cherchait une
formulation qui convienne à tout le
monde
entre de longues recherches d'un
compromis et plusieurs veto opposé
l'action du conseil de sécurité se
trouve paralysé au moment le plus
décisif
enfin votée en juillet la résolution
tant attendu arrive trop tard pour
remplir son but initial renforcer appuyé
l'appel d'antonio goûter reste en effet
c'est au tour du mois d'avril que ce
jouet les chu de sa campagne mondiale
dès son lancement son message résonne
fort sur le terrain et génère tout de
suite une impulsion positive en quelques
jours les premières actions concrètes
sont lancés dans quatre pays en conflit
ainsi une trêve unilatérale allant
jusqu'à 30 jours est décrété aux
philippines au cameroun en centrafrique
et en colombie dans tous ces cas
l'initiative revient au groupe rebelle
locaux le début est prometteur et une
percée globale semble imminente à la
plus grande satisfaction de l'onu qui ne
va pas pourtant duré en avril les trêves
sont instaurées et respecté par les
partis mais des violences persistent
cependant la responsabilité en revient
au groupe armé non affiliés aux accords
qui poursuivent leur combat
de plus face à la trêve de groupes
rebelles les autorités ne dépose pas
toujours leurs armes
attisant encore plus les hostilités les
quatre armistice expire vers mais
pourtant aucun d'entre eux n'est
prolonger ainsi l'élan s'essouffle en
quelques mois sans approcher vraiment un
règlement ces gestes de paix se solde
par un échec pourtant l'action est
encore moins tangible ailleurs dans le
monde
parmi les partisans de l'armée ce tease
seule une petite poignée d'acteurs agit
dans la pratique les actions
disparates n'indique pas vraiment les
violences tu es le cas par exemple en
birmanie ou en rdc
globalement l'impact de la trêve est
plus que limité vers août l'onu admet
l'échec de cette initiative
effectivement à notre grand regret dans
plusieurs cas la pandémie n'a pas poussé
les belligérants à suspendre les
hostilités ou à conclure un cessez le
feu permanent
cette campagne c'est la priorité au plan
global de réponse humanitaire covit 19
une approche internationale lancée en
mars qui visent spécifiquement cette
menace prégnante une action certes
importante qui manque tout de même de
mesures concrètes
si bien qu'un cri d'alarmé et un appel
aux dons est relancé en mai si nous ne
soutenons pas les plus pauvres surtout
les filles les femmes et d'autres
groupes vulnérables au moment où ils
affrontent la pandémie et les effets
d'une récession globale des retombées
vont se faire sentir pendant de longues
années
cette voie sera bien plus pénible est
beaucoup plus onéreuse pour tous mais au
mois d'août on trouve encore que
l'engagement financier international
dépasse à peine 20% des fonds
nécessaires un autre problème qui touche
cette année presque toutes les ong et
les programmes dead
mm le nu il s'agit des bouleversements
financiers mais aussi de nouvelles
priorités dead face à cette urgence
il ya un troisième facteur
incontournable le retrait des états unis
de plusieurs organismes mondiaux avec
pour raison officielle
la gestion plus efficace des aides
américaines officieusement d'autres
intérêts rentre bien évidemment en jeu
en effet pour donald trump la pandémie
ne change rien à ses priorités
géopolitiques
il faut exercer une pression maximale
sur l'iran et le venezuela et au pipi la
paix viendra au moyen-orient ce serait
très bien et l'iran sera très bien
neutralisé ils n'ont même pas pensé que
ça puisse être possible neutraliser
l'ennemi même s'il est déjà à terre
c'est la vision de la gestion de la
crise de donald trump le calcul
s'avèrent justes pour le venezuela
déjà saignés à vif par des sanctions son
économie s'écroule devant la récession
mondiale
la production pétrolière chute au niveau
de 1945 environ
le taux de pauvreté frôle 80% la
contraction du pib et s'annoncent
désastreuses avec -15 %
washington joue là dessus et un rom est
même une couche nouvelles sanctions ces
idées cargaison soutient l'opposition
tout est mis en oeuvre pour faire plier
le gouvernement
maduro de son côté l'iran se montre
peut-être plus tenace face aux défis et
bien pas immédiatement sa gestion
chaotique de l'épidémie mène à une
explosion du nombre d'infections dans
tout le pays dans le moyen orient
c'est le pays le plus touché par le
virus avec près de 400000 infections
épidémie persistante économie en panne
et des sanctions qui continuent à se
multiplier
l'iran semble face à une ans passés au 6
mai si un bond en juin un partenariat
stratégique est signée entre téhéran et
la chine
les injections de fonds chinois sont une
perfusion critique pour l'économie
iranienne
toujours privés d'accès aux marchés des
capitaux
de son côté pékin rêve d'intégrer l'iran
dans son réseau de la nouvelle route de
la soie pour y construire une nouvelle
voie entre l'asie et l'europe avec
l'iran comme rôle est stratégique pour
mieux comprendre l'impact de la pandémie
sur le monde géopolitique
nous revenons vers meriam benraad
docteur en sciences politiques de
l'institut d'études politiques de paris
tout d'abord parlons de la réponse
proposée par l'onu antonio guterres s
appelait pour le cessez le feu global
mais cette initiative a malheureusement
échoué
le nude doit-elle peut-être prendre une
approche plus décisive que ça selon vous
le problème de la gestion onusienne de
la pandémie
on va dire que tu largement duty latéral
ne fait que traduire une crise du
multilatéralisme qui ne remonte pas au
cofidis n'a ce que j'ai c'est d'ailleurs
dans mon dernier ouvrage le
multilatéralisme est en quelque sorte un
concept
aujourd'hui malheureusement un peu
obsolète mais ça remonte en fait vous
parliez des conflits ça remonte et non à
l'aiea
au début du millénaire avec un certain
nombre
intervention militaire qui ont été
décidé de manière unilatérale qui ont
provoqué des tensions extrêmes en sorte
qu au sein du conseil de sécurité et
entre grandes puissances
l'irak la libye ensuite la syrie bien
d'autres crises donc ceux là même qui
était finalement qui se voulait les
tenants du multilatéralisme un peu trahi
cette idée donc aujourd'hui on en paye
le prix parce qu'effectivement on voit
par exemple la suspicion à l'égard de
l'om est ce qui est accusé de faire le
jeu de la chine
on voit très bien qu'à l'assemblée de
l'onu
personne ne s'entend que les tensions
sont très vives le conseil de sécurité
est bloqué mais encore une fois c'est
pas le fait du coc vie 19
c'est parce que on a eu un ensemble de
d'événements qui ont en fait
complètement remise en cause la bonne
entente que les grands de ce monde avait
pu passer à une certaine époque donc
aujourd'hui va falloir d'une manière ou
d'une autre
relancer cette gestion multilatérale
mais encore faut-il qu'ils aient la
volonté
si on prend la mairie de trump par
exemple 30 n'est absolument pas dans une
logique de relance du multilatéralisme
il veut quitter l'om s il veut quitter
un certain nombre d'organisations
internationales et il serait un peu le
procès d'un taux comme il le comme il le
souhaite
dont tout cela et je dirais il est très
très beau sur le papier mais il faut des
actions concrètes et pour le moment
c'est plutôt une gestion unilatérale
très nationaliste finalement de la crise
qui prévoit parce qu'encore une fois on
a échoué par le passé à des corps a
donné vie à ce principe multilatérale il
ya une autre initiative onusienne
c'était la levée des sanctions ou du
moins leur assouplissement parfois et
celle ci a aussi échoué pourquoi selon
vous celle ci a échoué parce qu'en fait
on est dans un moment finalement on
parle du multilatéralisme
en fait ça fait quand même un moment si
on s'en tient aux théories ou des
relations internationales ça fait un
moment qu'on est revenu au réalisme
chaque état à sa stratégie la conduit
que ce soit en terme de sanction ou
comme je les dis de gestion interne des
crises on a absolument pas d'entente sur
toutes ces problématiques et surtout le
coguic 19 et une crise très géopolitique
là vous pose la question sur les
sanctions mais y'a pas que les sanctions
liées à la recherche d'un vaccin aussi
qui montre à quel point tout cela est
très en fait très géopolitique est très
réaliste la course au vaccin que autre
chose car aujourd'hui à la course au
vaccin mais très bien que les grands
états les grandes puissances sont dans
une compétition géopolitique ouverte ils
l'assument
d'où le doubs la faiblesse encore une
fois des organisations multilatérales
mais après il ne faut pas accuser je
dirais les états de vouloir aussi
conduire leurs propres stratégies dans
la mesure où ces rôles à succès par dans
ces institutions multilatérales sont
aussi quand même on peut le dire
largement incapable l2 proposer des
initiatives concrètes
donc c'est j'ai un cap une dynamique
simple c'est une problématique complexe
mais l'om est ce par exemple qui se
défend de sa gestion de la crise aurait
pu sur certains aspects il faut quand
même leur connaître un peu mieux gérer
les choses l'om est c'était un peu à la
traîne
on l'a vu dans les premiers mois de la
pandémie
donc tout cela et je dirais un peu
circulaire les états réagissent aussi à
ce fonctionnement institutionnel de ces
institutions
merci beaucoup madame bentrad je
rappelle myriam bedra docteur en
sciences politiques de l'institut
d'études politiques de paris et est
aujourd'hui avec nous merci encore
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage merci
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]